guys you're almost feeding me it's bound
to happen ready
hi this is snack Wars Christmas edition
full toilet
voila Oh blech speak British I love how
she just threw that to one side like
what is that we love good and dark and
dark and I think it's from Russia oh I
definitely have a favorite and I just
I'll just give it a rest give me the
purple one yes they are new are the
purple one it's the best that's got a
big knot in it and I like nuts like a
plastic log oh my god this looks good
you think they're different flavors oh
no I'm not
why is it scary no I'm not about this
you play as one all the way you can't be
a classic quality gloss agog oh that
one's quite sweet that's bit off I don't
mind it yeah I don't know about that
this one yeah this is way too sweet
horny this is great well it's hardly
bushi it's pretty Tony Italian oh yeah
obviously it's the time but I knew that
any now yeah I like it
wait no no no I have the one that you
set on fire best Christmas pudding
so what house thanks Christmas I guess I
said I'm about that
hello nice I love how Jesse's just
feeding me this is meant to be a double
act
I'm sorry someone gave me these odds
that I'd be so [ __ ] off this is not
really nice it's awfully dry Christmas
[Music]
cranberry you know what I can see why
that would be nice attack actually wait
wrong I'm gonna go with the cranberry
sauce
I'm liking about Chinese food ah guests
classic mince pie get in my belly
they're like meatballs
where's it from you try them on the back
of it I bought the Ben Spies all the way
I'm gonna send my spies not really funny
babies only needs Irish visit is that
right
okay
guys you're up for speeding me it's
bound to happen ready
stop eyeing up mine what are you looking
at three two one
I flied enough I thought B definitely
give me gummy eye
[Music]
you always smash these artistic things I
mean did you get a closer vassilis
indecent before it cracked and that will
snap walls Christmas edition guys
actually chose sake
[Music]